!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> LOOK AT YOU.
>> GREG: STOP IT.
STOP IT.
KEEP GOING.
DON'T STOP.
EVER.
HAPPY FRIDAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HIS AUDIENCE LAUGH ALL THE WAY
TO THE BANK.
TO DEPOSIT THEIR TICKET REFUNDS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: WRITER AND COMEDIAN JOE
MACKIE.
HE HAS A PUNCH FACE AS IN LET'S
DRINK SOME PUNCH IN HONOR OF
THIS HANDSOME MAN.
CO-HOST OF FOX AND FRIENDS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: SHE'S LIKE A CHRISTMAS
FRUITCAKE.
NUTTY, SWEET AND SOAKED IN RUM.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: AND FINALLY, HE'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE FAT LIPS
THAN COLLAGEN.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK, HEAVYWEIGHT
CHAMPION.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: ALL RIGHT.
BEFORE WE GET TO SOME NEW
STORIES IT'S FRIDAY SO THAT
MEANS IT'S TIME FOR THE LIVE
BULL RIDING EXHIBITION.
GET UP THERE, JOE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: ACTUALLY, I'M THE BULL.
I'M JOKING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: I'M JOKING.
IT'S TIME FOR THIS.
♪♪
>> GREG'S LEFTOVERS.
>> GREG: YES.
LEFTOVERS.
THE JOKES WE DIDN'T USE THIS
WEEK.
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME READING
THEM SO HERE WE GO.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS WON
A RECENT DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY POLL
THAT DID NOT INCLUDE JOE BIDEN.
THAT MAKES SENSE CONSIDERING SHE
HAS THE BLACK VOTE ALL LOCKED
UP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> TRUE.
>> GREG: I DON'T GET IT.
>> SHE WAS A HORRIBLE DH.
SHE PUT EVERYBODY IN JAIL.
>> GREG: [LAUGHING]
WOW!
THAT FLEW RIGHT OVER MY HEAD.
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
SPEAKING OF KAMALA, ANOTHER ONE
OF HER STAFFERS RESIGNED THIS
WEEK.
THIS TIME THE COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR JAMAL SIMMONS.
MORE STAFFERS SAY THEY WOULD
LIKE TO QUIT BUT THEY HATE
WAITING IN LINE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: SEE, I GOT THAT ONE.
THAT ONE -- BRITTNEY GRINER HAS
SAFELY RETURNED TO THE UNITED
STATES AFTER BEING RELEASED FROM
RUSSIAN CUSTODY LANDING SAFELY
IN SAN ANTONIO.
BUT UPON SEEING THE CONDITIONS
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER SHE
IMMEDIATELY ASKED TO GO BACK TO
RUSSIA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: SHE DOES LOOK LIKE PETE
DAVIDSON THERE.
>> GREG: FIRST, I DISAGREED BUT
SPEAKING OF TEXAS, A WOMAN THERE
ALLEGEDLY DROPPED OFF 50 POUNDS
OF HUMAN FECES AT A POLICE
STATION LAST WEEK BUT UPON
CLOSER INSPECTION IT TURNS OUT
IT WAS JUST BETAO ROURKE.
>> AN OHIO COUPLE MARRIED FOR 79
YEARS DIED JUST HOURS APART LAST
WEEK.
THE HUSBAND'S TOUCHING LAST
WORDS WERE FINALLY SOME TIME
ALONE.
>> GREG: I BET YOU A HUNDRED
DOLLARS THAT WILL BE A ONE MORE
THING, AND I'LL HAVE TO JUST
BITE MY TONGUE THROUGHOUT.
>> LET GERALDO HAVE HIS MOMENT.
>> GREG: A NEW STUDY FINDINGS
THAT BLOATING COULD BE AN ISSUE
FOR ONE IN SEVEN U.S. ADULTS
EVERY WEEK AND IF YOU SUFFER
FROM IT EVERY DAY ASK YOUR
DOCTOR IF YOU'RE MICHAEL MOORE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: THERE IS A FACE IN
THERE SOMEWHERE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN FACED A PRESS
OUTCRY AFTER AN ABUNDANCE OF
MEDIA MEMBERS WERE SMUBD FROM
HIS PARTY INCLUDING JOHN LINEN,
MARILYN MONROE AND TUPAC.
INDONESIA'S PARLIAMENT HAS VOTED
TO BAN SEX BEFORE MARRIAGE
CLAIMING IT'S A SIN.
HOWEVER, THEY MADE EXCEPTIONS
FOR DOGGY STYLE SINCE ALL DOGS
GO TO HEAVEN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: THAT WAS -- SOMEBODY --
JOE, DID YOU WRITE THAT?
>> NO, I HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT.
>> GREG: WHO DO YOU THINK WROTE
THAT?
>> I DIDN'T WRITE THAT I DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
>> GREG: WE'RE NOT GOING FORWARD
UNTIL WE FIND OUT WHO WROTE
THAT.
FORMER NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR CHRIS
CHRISTIE'S NIECE WAS ACCUSED OF
BITING AND INJURING A COP DURING
A MELTDOWN ON AN AIRPLANE.
IT WAS SAID TO HAVE STARTED
AFTER CHRIS CHRISTIE ATE THE
CAPTAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: I MEAN, THEY LAUGHED AT
IT, SO I GUESS IT'S OKAY.
JONATHAN, TORTOISE, WORLD'S
OLDEST LIVING LAND CREATURE
CELEBRATED HIS 190TH BIRTHDAY
THIS WEEK.
HE SAYS THE KEY WAS JUST TAKING
EVERY DAY REALLY SLOW.
>> THAT'S GOOD FOR A KID'S
PARTY.
>> GREG: YES.
THE TRAILER FOR THE NEW INDIANA
JONES MOVIE STARRING AN
80-YEAR-OLD HARRISON FORD WAS
RELEASED LAST WEEK.
AND YOU COULD TELL THEY ARE
TAKING A MORE REALISTIC APPROACH
THIS TIME AROUND.
IN THE FIRST SCENE HE SHOOTS A
COMMERCIAL FOR A RELIEF ACTOR.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: IT'S NO BALANCE OF
NATURE.
JOKING.
THEY ARE BOTH EQUALLY WONDERFUL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: AND FINALLY, THE MAKERS
OF AMERICAN GIRL DOLLS HAVE
ANGERED PARENTS WITH A
CHILDREN'S BOOK PROMOTING GENDER
FLUIDITY AND FOR GIRLS WITH
PENISES, THE BOOK IS A AVAILABLE
AS A POP-UP.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: IS THAT YOURS?
>> NO, THAT WASN'T MINE EITHER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: THAT'S GREAT.
TO SOME ACTUAL NEWS CONFIRMING
WHAT WE ALREADY KNEW, PRE-MUSK
TWITTER HATED ME AND YOU.
COMPILED IN ANOTHER BATCH OF
FILES.
TWITTER LIED ABOUT DETAILS, THEY
SECRETLY HAD THEIR THUMB ON THE
SCALE.
IN A NEW DUMP LAST NIGHT WE'VE
LEARNED THAT THE SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANY DID, IN FACT, ENGAGE IN
SO-CALLED SHADOWBANNING OF
CONSERVATIVE ACCOUNTS.
MAKING THEM MORE INVISIBLE THAN
JOY -- AT A CATTLE RANCH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: EVEN THOUGH -- DON'T
CLAP.
DON'T CLAP.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: NO, STOP CLAPPING.
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO CLAP.
EVEN THOUGH TWITTER EXECUTIVES
ALWAYS DENIED IT AND MAKE
REPUBLICANS LOOK LIKE CON
SPURISTS, PREVENTING FAVORITE
TWEETS FROM TRENDING, OR EVEN
TRENDING TOPICS, ALL IN SECRET
WITHOUT INFORMING USERS.
AMONG THE ACCOUNTS COVERTLY
TARGETED CHARLIE KIRK, LIBS OF
TIK TOK AND OUR VERY OWN DAN
BONGINO.
NOT BONGINO, GOD, I LOVED HIS
SONG "LIVING ON A PRAYER."
[Laughter]
>> GREG: SO ALL THESE NEW FACTS
ARE COMING OUT NOW THANKS TO
ELON MUSK.
IT ONLY COST HIM $44 BILLION.
A SMALL PRICE TO PAY FOR THE
TRUTH, ESPECIALLY SINCE NUMBER
OF US HAS TO PAY FOR IT.
JOE, THE FIRST THING I DID WHEN
I WAS UP LAST NIGHT WAS WAITING
FOR A TWEET MENTIONING THAT I
WAS SHADOW BANNED, AND I WASN'T,
AND I WAS SO BUMMED.
I WAS WAITING FOR BARI WEISS TO
AT MITT, THAT, TO ME IS THE
COOLEST GROUP.
JOE: MAYBE YOU WERE SHADOW
BANNED AND THEY HAVEN'T HAD THE
GUTS TO RELEASE IT.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY I WAS SHADOW
BANNED, BECAUSE SOME OF MY JOKES
DIDN'T GO VIRAL.
[LAUGHTER]
JOE: OR THEY WEREN'T GOOD.
JOE: I HATE IT WHEN SOMEONE
MAKES A DECISION ABOUT YOU BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE COURAGE TO
TELL YOU TO YOUR FACE, YOU KNOW.
LIKE ONE TIME THIS LADY, YOU
KNOW, GOES TO ME, WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO GO ON A DATE, AND I
HAD TO FILL OUT A MISSING
PERSON'S REPORT OVER THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: YES.
JOE: THAT WAS KIND OF A SAD END
BUT IT WAS BETWEEN THAT AND THE
TIME I GOT STOOD UP AT THE
TENNIS COURT.
>> GREG: WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
JOE: IT'S A LOT OF CHASING
TENNIS BALLS WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
COURT BY YOURSELF.
>> GREG: AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
WAITING.
JOE: YES, WELL, I HAD IT
RESERVED SO THAT WAS TOO BAD.
>> GREG: I'LL DO THAT WHEN I
HAVE RESERVATIONS AND ARE STOOD
UP ON DATE, I'M JUST, I'LL EAT
HERE BY MYSELF.
JOE: FOOD TASTES THE SAME WHEN
YOU'RE ALONE.
>> DID YOU DO ANYTHING WHEN YOU
KEPT MAKING EXCUSE WHOSE THE
WAITER CAME BY, IT MUST HAVE
BEEN AN ACCIDENT.
THIS IS CRAZY.
>> I JUST HAD TO GET AWAY FROM
ALL OF MY FRIENDS FOR A MINUTE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: TODD -- YOU KNOW, IF
ELON MUSK NEVER BOUGHT THIS WE
WOULD NEVER KNOW ABOUT THIS.
ISN'T THAT INCREDIBLE?
HE GOT PISSED OFF BECAUSE THEY
BANNED BABYLON BEE.
THAT'S WHAT PISSED HIM OFF.
WHEN YOU'RE REALLY RICH, IF ONE
THING MISSES YOU OFF, YOU CAN
JUST BUY THE THING THAT -- YOU
OFF.
>> IT'S LITERALLY BEING THE
RICHEST GUY EVER, LITERALLY IN
THE HISTORY OF MONEY, IN THE
HISTORY OF CURRENCY BUT TO YOUR
POINT OBVIOUSLY WE WOULDN'T KNOW
ANY OF THIS IF HE DIDN'T MAKE
THAT DECISION AND WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD SO MANY ON THE LEFT
SAYING, THIS IS A NOTHING
BURGER.
WE KNEW ALL OF THIS.
NO, WE DIDN'T KNOW THIS.
THIS IS THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF A
NOTHING BURGER.
THIS IS LIKE ONE OF THOSE
BURGERS YOU GET AT A STATE FAIR
AND HAS ALL THE FRIED KRAN OTHER
IT, JACK DORSEY HAS BEEN SAYING
SOME WEIRD THINGS LIKE GOING
AFTER HIS BUDDY ELON MUSK FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS.
DORSEY TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS UNDER OATH THAT THIS
WASN'T HAPPENING.
>> DO YOU THINK HE DIDN'T KNOW?
>> I DON'T SEE HOW YOU CAN RUN A
COMPANY AND NOT KNOW.
HE WAS IN ON SOME OF THESE
MEETINGS AND HE MAY TRY TO PARSE
THE LANGUAGE, IT'S ALL THE SAME
EFFECT PUTTING CONSERVATIVES
DOWN BELOW OR ELIMINATING THEM
ON TWITTER, ESPECIALLY GOING
INTO ELECTIONS AND THAT'S WRONG.
>> GREG: I WOULD ARGUE THAT HE
WAS INTERESTED IN A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS AND HE HAD TERRIBLE
MIDDLE MANAGERS.
THEY WERE ALL LEFT WINGERS, AND
THEY WERE LIKE, AND THEY WERE
LYING TO HIM.
>> YOU MIGHT BE RIGHT.
>> AGREED.
I THINK BOTH THINGS CAN BE
RIGHT.
I JUST THINK, YES.
>> I THINK I CAN BE RIGHT AND
YOU CAN BE WRONG.
>> AFTER ALL I DID FOR YOU AT
BEGINNING OF THIS SHOW.
>> DID YOU A LOT.
BOY, IF YOU ONLY KNEW WHAT HE
DID FOR ME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> BUT YOU WILL SOON ENOUGH WHEN
WE DO IT AS A SEGMENT NEXT WEEK
ON MONDAY, I CAN'T WAIT.
HERE'S THE THING, TO TODD'S
POINT THEY DENIED THAT IT
HAPPENED AND WHEN IT HAPPENED
THEY SAID, OH, THEY SAID, OH,
YES, THAT THING.
THAT'S PART OF OUR POLICY.
WE TRY TO MAKE SURE SOMETHING
DANGEROUS ISN'T ON OUR SOCIAL
PLATFORM.
THAT WE WEREN'T SHADOWBANNING,
WE WERE JUST BASICALLY TRYING TO
CONTROL SOMETHING HARMFUL.
KAT: WE WEREN'T SHADOWBANNING
BECAUSE WE WEREN'T CALLING IT
THAT AND THAT WAS THEIR SERIOUS
ANSWER.
I'M HAVING A REALLY HARD TIME
GETTING WORKED UP ABOUT THIS
STUFF BECAUSE I ALREADY KNEW
THIS WAS HAPPENING.
BECAUSE I DECIDED TO INSTEAD
TRUST WHAT I WAS SEEING AND
HEARING, INSTEAD OF THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE TELLING ME THAT I
WASN'T SEEING AND HEARING THAT.
WHICH IS WHAT THEY D. I WAS JUST
TRUSTING MYSELF WHICH IS CRAZY.
AGAIN, I ALSO WANTED TO KNOW,
JUST BECAUSE YOU ARE ON THAT
LIST DOESN'T MEAN YOU WERE OR
YOU WEREN'T.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW.
I THINK A LOT OF US WERE.
>> GREG: ARE YOU SAYING YOU'RE
SHADOWBANNING YOUR
SHADOWBANNING?
KAT: I THINK ALL OF US HERE,
WHEN IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT MUSK
WAS CONSIDERING IT A LOT OF OUR
FOLLOWER ACCOUNTS, OUR HUGE
FOLLOWER ACCOUNTS, HAD HUGE
BUMPS AND NOT HAPPENING FOR
PEOPLE -- CERTAIN ASSOCIATIONS,
LIKE, OKAY, YOU WORK AT FOX NEWS
OR THINGS LIKE THAT THERE WAS
SOME KIND OF ALGORITHM AND IF
THEY WOULD HAVE ADMITTED IT NONE
OF THIS WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
>> GREG: IT'S AN INTERESTING
POINT.
WHEN SOMEBODY FINDS OUT THE
POLICE ARE COMING THEY WILL
FLUSH THE DRUGS DOWN THE TOILET,
RIGHT?
JOE KNOWS WHAT I MEAN.
IN THIS CASE IT WAS LET'S
RESTORE THE TWITTER FOLLOWERS TO
THE PEOPLE WE HATE, BEFORE THEY
LOOK AT IT.
VERY INTERESTING.
TYRUS, THEIR EXCUSE WAS ALWAYS
BRANDING YOU A DANGER FIRST AND
THAT GIVES THEM THE REASON.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT.
THEY WOULD SAY THAT IF YOU WERE
CRITICAL OF BABYLON BEE, YOU
MISS GENDERED SOMEONE, WOULD YOU
BE PUTTING THEM IN DANGER AND
YOU NEED TO BE BANNED.
>> IT'S NOT EVEN THAT DEEP.
FIRST, PUTTING THINGS BACK, THAT
ALWAYS WORKS.
YOU STEAL MOM AND DAD'S ALCOHOL,
PUT WATER IN IT AND PUT IT BACK,
YOU THINK IT WILL BE THE SAME?
NO, IT WILL BE WATERED DOWN AND
MESSED UP.
THEY DID THAT TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
IT'S EASY TO SEE WHO WAS SHADOW
BANNED AND BLOCKED.
EVERY TIME WE DEAL WITH THESE
PEOPLE THEY HAVE THESE GOD
COMPLEXES AND THEY ONLY SURROUND
THEMSELVES WITH PEOPLE WHO THINK
LIKE THEM AND DO LIKE THEM THEY
VIRTUE SIGNAL LIKE I BLOCKED
GUTFELD!.
WHAT WE DON'T LOOK AT, IS FOR
ENTERTAINERS WHO ARE
CONSERVATIVE, THEY AFTER FITTED
THEIR LIVELIHOODS.
THEY AFFECTED THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE MONEY, TO GET JOBS.
PEER SWEET JOE HERE FOUGHT BUT
HE WAS HAVING WRITER'S BLOCK.
HE THOUGHT HIS JOKES WERE WEIRD
AND UNFUNNY AND CREEPY AND NO
ONE WAS PAYING ATTENTION TO
THEM.
ALL ALONG, HE'S DROPPING
SHAKESPEARE GOLD, AND THEY ARE
CRUCIFYING HIM BECAUSE HE
BELIEVES IN SMALL GOVERNMENT.
AND WE LAUGH ABOUT THAT, AND ME,
I THOUGHT, I DIDN'T KNOW ANY
BLACK PEOPLE ANYMORE.
>> LO AN